[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale leçon pour débutants avec ninon
maisuradze et bonjour nino bonjour alors
aujourd'hui on va parler dans cette
leçon pour apprendre le jeu d'échecs
on va parler de la valeur des pièces
assez important parce que quand on veut
faire des échanges
quand on veut aussi compter le matériel
qu'on a ou le matériel qu'on a pris à
l'adversaire il faut quand même
connaître à peu près la valeur des
pièces
oui c'est essentiel aux échecs de savoir
voilà c'est qu'ils écoutent plus et
qu'ils votent moins on sait qu'il faut
garder c'est qu'il faut échanger et sait
donc comment vous initier tout de suite
on va vous initier à cette valeur des
pièces comme on peut regarder la valeur
d'écrire on vous rappelle donc
kelly à leroy donc vous êtes on peut
marquer donc quand lyon c'est la dame
juste à côté
les fous donc les cavaliers les tours et
c'est fou et bien sûr les pions qui sont
les cavaliers dont on va montrer
tranquillement ici les cavaliers les
tours les tours voilà et enfin arte qui
reste c'est des pions blancs et les
pions noirs ont souvent à 6000 avec les
soldats donc les pions saisine qui est
ce qui coûte le moins et on dit pour
mieux comprendre que saint valère dans
un voilà le pion voit donc c'est la base
de comptage évidemment du jeu d'échec
c'est la pièce la moins la moins
puissante donc on lui donne une valeur
de 1
là si on comptait ça tous les pions
qu'on a donc ça va faire 8 par exemple
on aurait huit points ici effectivement
donc question après la dame c'est une
pièce la plus pure puissante 1 ça vaut 9
on dit il est certes un leurre qui
disent certains afghans
en tout cas c'est évident que c'est la
puissante moi je vous conseille plutôt
compter comme naf donc la dame vaut 9
d'accord plutôt neuf que 10 il ya deux
écoles donc on dire à 9 ou 10 mai donc
plutôt neuf ont été toutes façons ça
change pas grand chose parce que vous
allez voir c'est beaucoup plus puissants
que les autres pièces et c'est une
évidence
soit 9 soit 10 de façon il faut garder
et pas donner facilement cette place 9
ou 10 donc les fous par exemple on les
fout chaque question c'est 3 donc mais
c'est bien de terminer pratiquement né à
cette version ça coûte 3 3 donc un fou
un fonds peut dire qu'on fout vos trois
pions quoi oui ces armes
voilà donc deux fois en même temps ça
pourrait faire 6 pions par exemple donc
le cavalier c'est la même chose ça coûte
3 donc le câble et comme le fou niveau 3
donc je soutiens marcheurs cavaliers fou
tout de suite
comment déterminer par rapport le four
ils se foutent bien sûr les 2 3 ils ont
la même valeur mais juste à retenir dès
maintenant que dans les positions
ouvertes c'est le fou qui sera plus fort
alors que dans les positions fermes et
ce sera le chaos league voilà sauter sur
les pieds ce qui sera plus fort voilà
donc
dépendra un peu du style de la position
mais on peut dire 3 3 pour chacune des
deux brillait s'appropriait mahler et
après suivant les positions mais lui ne
pourra prendre le dessus sur l'autre
mais c'est des paramètres après qu'ils
sont plus des paramètres de valeur mais
des paramètres positionnelle oui et il
nous reste les taux métaux alors combien
vaut le tour donc là encore c'est un
type aux devises l avis là dessus il ya
certes un livre qui dit 5 et les autres
quatre et demi et voilà où je crois tu
étais dans des petits pots stéphane moi
j'ai appartiennent à l'école qui
considère ça coûte 4 et demi quatre et
demi alors on pourrait considérer
effectivement que la tour vaut 5 sachant
qu'on donc deux tours val d'is et valent
peut-être un peu plus qu'une dame mais
en fait ça dépend dans des positions
il faut dire qu'elle sache et qui a par
exemple déjà remarqué m on indiqué la
dame côte 9 d'accord donc si on prend
trois pièces comble doffou est encore
lié par exemple de fouet chacun 3 3 3 ça
donne également neuf et ont l'impression
est ce vrai donc ça simplement l'air ça
le même valeur mais sachez qu est très
souvent plus on est divisé donc les
forces
ce sera toujours un type au mieux par
exemple la dame qui va juste se déplacer
tout seul c'est juste une seule pièce il
peut pas se diviser être partout alors
que trois pièces qui veut le même
qu'elle me valère quand même ils ont c
est comment dire allez partout sur
l'échiquier à gauche à droite
ouais ça fait plus de force ça fait un
retard c'est pour ça c'est pour cette
raison c'est pas forcément qu'est la
tour cote 5 et 2 tours donne et mieux
que la dame non et je pense que comme
les tours sont s'ils sont divisés mexico
4 et demi et donc chacun va doit
ordonner neuf comme la valeur des dames
mais comme les détours il pc c'est plus
souple en fait avoir d'oublier ces
manoeuvres et comme on veut c'est pour
ça peut-être ce sera préférable que vous
avez deux tours dans certaines positions
qu'elle est d'accord donc résumons nous
les tours va le 5 ou 4 et demi
bon les fous et les cavaliers bâle iii
la dame vos soit 9 soit 10 subventions
comme on considère les choses on peut
dire tour cinq dames
10 ou alors pour quatre et demi d'âmes
neuf ça change pas grand chose les pions
balin donc ça s'est fait ailleurs le
royaume combien donc le roi c'est une
bonne question basque est souvent
beaucoup de livres disques
le roi n'a pas de valeur c'est
inestimable parce que comme on ne peut
pas échanger le roi ou savait que les
voir ce que le bout de partie du coup il
dit à quoi ça sert de donner valeur roi
mais c'est mieux de connaître comme la
valeur de roy hill un certain valeur
notamment dans les finales vous allez
voir quand vous allez changer les pièces
et l'europe centralisée on peut aller
loin
là on dit ça coûte 3 comme ça c'était le
fou ou le corps une fois donc quand il
joue quand leur rôle actif on peut
considérer qu'il ya un rôle de 3,6 ne
vous allez remarquer dans pratiquement
tous les partis
le roi reste le coût en cash et pour ce
qu'elle ne reçoit pas le match ouais
c'est pour ça ça va pas le grand chose
mettre le coin caché sur casse derrière
c'est pour ça on dit que partiquement il
n'y a pas de salaire pour le roi oui
mais attention à la fin ça peut devenir
une pie des pièces puissante mais ça
peut devenir une pièce puissante
effectivement qu'il ya une certaine
valeur d'activité mais on peut pas les
changer donc on peut pas dire j'échange
mon roi qui vaut 3 contre le fou qui
vous 3 parce que c'est interdit
évidemment le roi c'est le but du jeu
c'est de le mater il peut pas se mettre
en échec et on peut pas donc le prendre
fait d'ailleurs sur le mot échange on
nous explique qu est-ce que qu'est ce
que ça signifie effet qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'un exemple un exemple ici
deux parties donc e4 e5 voilà les pions
qui veulent au centre deux cavaliers sur
la case f3 qu'avait laissé six pour les
noirs est un exemple des changes ici les
blancs jouent le coup trois des quatre
donc il joue le pion central ici sur la
case des les noirs peuvent évidemment
ici prendre échangé à échanger ici sur
la case des cartes et donc ça va donner
en échange de pions donc on prend un
pion qui vaut 1 et on reprend un pion
qui voit donc c'est équilibré nous et
surtout les change ça peut signifier
plusieurs choses mais surtout c'est au
sens quand on échange des pièces de
nouvelles aires quand même on échange et
pièces de même valeur là un autre
exemple par exemple regarder car les
plans des quatre d'en prendre quatre ont
fait d'échanger un cavalier qui vaut
trois contre un cavalier qui vous 3 donc
c'est un simple échange
voilà et sur dame et si cela aussi on
fait
échanges puisque on échange la dame
contre la dame donc on échange 10.10.10
toujours des forces totalement
équilibrée alors si on venus un coup
arrière et stefan en cours et juste
montrons encore en cours ici par exemple
si on prenait dans le 17è ce qu'on peut
prendre dans des cités alors si on
faisait dame prend pions et 7 on aurait
pris un pion avec la dame et en plus on
fait donc c'est une sorte de change mais
très très défavorable c'est pas une
chose est pratiquement perdu de la dame
on a pris un point en fait oui pions
regardez là on a pris donc avec notre
n'a fou disque il à différentes écoles
n'ont rien dire alors les noirs peuvent
prendre la dame avec le fou oui il ya
plus échec a pas de problème on peut
prendre et donc là on a perdu 10 points
on doit faire les unes à fovu point
cette dépense qu'on a pris un point et
on a donné 10 naples a donc on a perdu
beaucoup là on va perdu on a perdu
presque huit ou neuf cents ces échanges
la plus catastrophique que vous vous
refaire voilà moi il faut pas faire ce
genre d'échangé midi donc l'ont bien
retenir 2
le conte pour passer tromper vous
remarqué par exemple le fouet la tour
calculer combien ça peut donner faut
trois tours c'est entre cinq et quatre
et demi donc ça fait sur cette idée me
soit 8 kg ou par exemple capturez de
pied c'est donner votre dame s'est
toujours pas suffisant oui parce que la
dame donc vous presque 10 donc l'a8 donc
on perdrait 2 points alors on va montrer
un autre exemple aussi des changes qui
est pas favorable
oui par exemple un échange typique après
cavale et c6 les blancs jouent le coup
pousser 400 immeubles les noirs fous ces
cinq les blancs joue cavalier sur la
case d3 et la cavalière 6 pour les noirs
alors on deck les lutins les débutants
aime bien la prise sur la case f7 cirque
effectivement le fou ici attaque la case
s est alors on joue le cri il ya
certains qui prend le même directement
dans sa aussi bien sûr à éviter alors si
on se rend directement fou qui vaut 3
prend un pion qui voit le roi prend le
fou on a le droit parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'échec
et là vous comprenez que vous n'avez pas
capturer grand chose et c'est pas sympa
le coup vous avez pris un pion alors
vous avez donné un fou qui vaut 3 donc
c'est pas terrible donc aux a perdu
quand nous avons perdu nous pillons
voilà alors une autre solution pour
faire cet échange fait un échange qui
pourrait être avantageux c'est de jouer
le coup ici au regard des cavaliers g5
alors le cavalier ici attaque le pion à
vii le fou attaque le pion et 7 donc que
les noirs peuvent pas trop le défendre
si on défend avec la dame l'a démontré
d'ailleurs d'un mécène par exemple adams
est la dame baudis on vous rappelle donc
six langues par exemple on prend on
prend la dame prend le cavalier par
exemple le fou reprend la dame et le roi
reprend bilan des courses alors calculé
calculer combien qu'est ce que ça a fait
à votre avis
donc les blancs regardez on appris en
pions et les dames et les noirs ils ont
pris toutes pièces et donc de payer 7 6
alors que puis on est d'ordre c'est
entre 10 et 11
vous voyez c'est pratiquement on a fait
des changes est doublement les noirs ont
fait doublement perdante
voilà donc c'est pas bon du tout pour
les noirs puisque nous donner quelque
chose qui fêteront ce même 10 et 11 en
fait avec le pion contre eux quelque
chose qui vaut 3 +36 sont par contre les
noirs pourrez choisir un autre
quant au lieu de jouer le coup d'un bus
est ici ils peuvent jouer le coup petit
rock
alors petit rôle pourquoi parce que
gardez donc le cavalier attaqué la case
et 7 ainsi que le fou en faisant petit
rock qui est possible puisque le roi
n'était pas en échec la tohu le roi
n'avait pas joué il n'y a pas de pièces
entre le roi ils à tours on a pu rockets
et les blancs font quand même le coup
ici cavaliers prend à vii ou là alors
donc avalé premier set une fois voilà
une fois que le pointu rock a été fait
on
ils prennent la casse pourquoi on vous
montre ça c'est pas tout simplement
montrer un simple échange mais parce que
c'est une position très typique on vous
fréquentez secondes soit exactement
comme ça soit un petit peu varié et
beaucoup de beaucoup de débutants sont
attirés donc par ses pions et par la
tour surtout oui ils pensent que c'est
bien échangé du ps donc en relief ou
contre empiler les doigts et ça vous
vous trompez si vous pensez comme ça
parce que c'est vraiment déplorable et
là stéphane d'ailleurs à remarquer c'est
pour ça aussi
moi je pense c'est important précis
c'est pour moi la tour côte plutôt
quatre et demi parce que par exemple
quand on dit la tour coûte 5
on prend un pion et la tour ça fait déjà
6 alors ici on va voir ce qui se passe
ici les noirs prennent ici cavaliers ont
fait faux prophètes et après roy prend
headset on a donné deux pièces leurs
trois plus trois mais on a pris
effectivement une tour est un pion donc
ça fait six ans que l'école qui compte
qu'est la tour coûte 5 sahafa 6,6 donc
c'est pour ça je crois que ces gens de
position créer un type ont envie quitter
en a un parmi les débutants
oui et je pense y ont dit quelques tours
côte plutôt quatre et demi ça se voit
tout de suite que c'est un petit peu
quand même deux favorables pour oui bien
sûr là mais sinon une autre raison
dans le milieu du haut var était lui
aussi avoué cavaliers que beaucoup plus
+ 5 et la corruption
et pourquoi maintenant on va passer
derrière sur l'explication de pièces
légères et lourdes
on vous expliquait qu est ce que ça
signifie donc aux échecs on divise les
pièces ont dit la dame et les tours se
sont le ps lourdes et le cavalier le fou
ce sont les pièces légères oui déjà en
terme de
2 en termes de prix est évidemment une
tour 4 il est fou les cavaliers ne
valent que 3 et la dame n'en parlons pas
le goût elle vaut 10 ans et 2 et par
rapport à celle bien d'autres et jérémy
est lourde des dons qu'a vraiment
quelles sont les pièces lourdes rentrer
dans le jours plus tard pourquoi parce
que comme ça coûte cher on n'a pas à lui
les pertes donc si on rentre très tôt
dans le centre ce sera attaqué très
facilement par exemple cavaliers qui
coûte 3 pions qui coûte 1 on n'a pas nui
changer notre dame que coûte 10 contrats
qui ont comme on a vu donc c'est pas
favorable et c'est que je veux dire par
là c'est pourquoi deux pièces au milieu
du haut et plus fort comme dans cette
position une fallait pas changer parce
que les pires sort très facilement dès
le début légère je veux dire entre les
pièces lourdes comme la tour serait
fuite et on peut réunir un type au
médiateur pour vous montrer il était
plus passive
vous voyez les tours actuellement
médecin dès le début de partie il ne
participe pas un participant à l'ets
bloqué par son pion ici à l'attack rien
et effectivement elle est comme elle
vaut cher en plus des garde temps
qu'avec ce qu'une pièce inférieur 1 dès
qu'on attaque avec une pièce inférieures
cette tour elle va devoir me bouger
parce que sinon on va perdre quatre
points et demi face à trois points donc
ça c'était un type au pourvoi indique
côté stratégique mais sinon pour
l'instant retenez bien la voilure de
pièces comme il a parlé donc 3 les
cavaliers et les fous les quatre et demi
la tour au sol jusqu'à 5 ans pions et
roy inestimable vers le final 3 la dame
entre 9 et 10 voilà voilà on a fait le
tour de la valeur de ces pièces et puis
les échanges donc on peut faire ou ne
pas faire
donc on vous conseille certainement pas
d'échangé deux pièces face à une tour
c'est pas une bonne affaire même même
avec une tour de plus c'est pas c'est
pas une très bonne affaire sur ce alors
attention si vous prenez torre d'opinion
ça serait différente dans lanaudière
c'est assez près donc de chair c'est
plus cher déjà effectivement donc il
faut être précis il faut faire faut
faire des comptes d'apothicaire
quasiment il faut être extrêmement
précis une balance et on va là vous
voyez comment placer un petit peu la
volée requis qui fait merci nino pour
cette leçon spéciale valeur des pièces
qui nous permet maintenant de mieux
savoir quand c'est qu'on peut faire ou
pas des échanges
therrien au roi et à bientôt au revoir
merci
[Musique]